John Green: Hi, I'm John Green and this is
not Crash Course.
Today we're celebrating July 4th here at the
Crash Course studios, which is why I'm wearing
my Costa Rica shirt.
To celebrate the United States today, we're
having our annual hot dog eating contest here
at the Crash Course Indianapolis studios.
Pretty simple contest: How many hot dogs can
you eat in 4 minutes?
The winner wins the Golden Fork.
But really, it's not about money or the Golden
Fork, or the non-existent cash prize.
It's about national pride.
John Green: Hi.
I'm John Green, I'm the host of Crash Course,
Mentalfloss, Vlogbrothers, sometimes the Art
Assignment.
Sarah Green: I'm Sarah Urist Green, I'm host
of the Art Assignment.
Aaron Carroll: I'm Aaron Carroll, I'm the
writer and host of Healthcare Triage.
Stan Muller: My name's Stan Muller, and I
work on pretty much everything we make here.
Mark Olsen: Hi, my name's Mark Olsen, and
I direct the Art Assignment and Mentalfloss.
Meredith Danko: I'm Meredith Danko, I'm the
head writer of Mentalfloss, and I'm the assistant
manager of the AFC Wimbly-Womblys.
Brandon Brungard: I'm Brandon Brungard, I'm
the video editor for Mentalfloss, Crash Course,
and the Art Assignment.
Paige Finch: I'm Paige Finch and I'm an intern.
Jack Stanton: My name is Jack Stanton, I'm
the intern here.
Alex: (Sits on chair)
JG: I'm super confident that I'm not going
to win, but I'm also confident that I am not
going to be last.
SG: I'm not a professional eater.
I like to eat, but I like to do it slowly.
AC: Nah, I don't think very good.
I'll do better than ninth.
SM: The good old fashion gut pack is long
been a skill that I've had.
MO: What gives me confidence this year is
knowing that no matter who wins, we all actually
lose together.
MD: My confidence level's very high, even
though I have re-watched last year's and I
know everyone made fun of me because I said
I was going to do well and I didn't.
Still very high.
BB: I haven't eaten in, like, 20 hours or
so, so I'm pretty hungry, so I think I'll
do pretty well.
PF: I am pretty positive that I'm going to
lose.
JS: I've been training for this my entire
life.
(Hard to tell who says what due to mouths
full of hot dogs)
John: Alright
(Laughter, moaning)
Various : Ewww, Oh my God, I wish I had blinders
that was disgusting,
Gross
JG: You married me
JG Worried about Jack,
We have 3 minutes,
My jaws are getting tired
First of all these hot dogs taste awesome
SG: He's the competition.
I already beat last year
JG: You can do it better, come on you can
do it
BB I'm starting to get sweaty
It's the lights
John's gonna break his (...)
You ate like a hot dog and a half
What's the reversal of fortune time limit?
Before the four minutes.
Effective immediately?
... for the title
Ok Meredith?
One minute left!
At some point you realise you can't possibly
win
Narrator: You have 34 seconds left.
It's what's in your mouth when the timer goes?
I don't know
?: I can't swallow it
Take it, dad, take it.
Go, daddy, go!
N: You have 18 seconds left
10,9,8,7,6,5,4,3,2,1 Timer is done!
JG: Stan, it is my privilege and also my responsibility
to give you the Golden Hot Dog.
(Everyone claps and cheers)